foreign
[Music]
you think your wife can hear you
no
white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
New Management we've been
since we
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
for result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
let's go
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartender it's not really
what I do what is it that you really do
okay
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we're gonna wake them up
with a wave of passion they've never
felt before hell yeah without further
Ado I give you the Visionary artist
Magic Mike
like
so what's the show about it's the same
more will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick
the real question is why does she feel
like she has to choose it sounds to me
she just needs to let go
[Music]
I'm good
maybe that as well
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whenever she wants
[Music]
there's a cop right is your arrest her
what's your name Kim
lets you out for the warning right
foreign
s came pouring over the 38th parallel
This Is War and we're up
we know this day might come it doesn't
make it any easier
[Music]
commanding officer called you one of the
best Pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being the Naval aviator
it's the toughest job there is Jim
thinks that you'd be in a squadron with
a colored Aviator
can't take it how many times people have
told me to give up quit
that I even
that's why you can't always do what
you're told
what do you want me to do just be
balling man you belong in the sky
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
I need everyone sharp and ready those
boys are going on by their fingernails
we bring everyone
home
and then would you fighting for
[Applause]
show off that was pretty good it's good
you are down to your last life
[Music]
oh
brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
I'm supposed to be a furious hero a
legend this is a person party that's
your party so this
[Applause]
is let's talk
no hablo English
I don't speak Spanish either you're
funny uh what's your story my story
[Music]
oh no
Legend tell us
waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great posing
boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish to get me my lives
back okay okay possum face I won't make
your bag but first out
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily what's in Boots Goldie there's
all right
[Music]
without life to spare I am nothing when
you only have one life that's what makes
it special go get him tiger hey take it
easy
this is gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Whitney Houston
[Applause]
uh common criticism of you your music
isn't black enough who said that that's
just Bull and it makes me angry actually
it's hateful and uninformed a whole life
she ain't black no she ain't white
enough well how about she's not obedient
enough
how about she ain't fearful enough
[Music]
music is not a color to me it has no
boundaries I sing what I want to sing
be how I want to be and reach as big an
audience as I can
I love you no one is like you you can
sing
Whitney your daddy's princess
we're building something here so you
just keep singing Daddy
my money
trusted you do you want me to look out
for me
[Music]
YouTubers spent a lot of time together
it's damaging the brand since the winter
little girl become the brand I miss that
don't even worry about it you're Whitney
Houston
[Music]
[Applause]
love
[Applause]
best woman I ever know
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
oh
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
[Music]
Final Approach to Target
[Music]
okay you got seven minutes stay focused
the art in here is worth millions
proceed to step two
what's happening
it won't open sorry man you're on your
own
coming in number three
number three comment
help me get me out of here
got a Duncan Square Park
see do that for me
tell him I'm stuck here
[Applause]
nobody here but us pigeons
[Music]
I feel you brother I gotta set you free
when I was a kid My teacher asked what I
would say from my house if it were on
fire
I answered a Sketchbook my AC DC album
and my Campground show I didn't mention
my parents were my sister
does that make me a bad person
cat died
music face
but Art
Is For Keeps
[Music]
foreign
how good a woman your mama was
she took Colton Briggs the coldest
killer that I've ever met and she turned
him into a family man
my mama's dead now
[Applause]
they're another
foreign
there's
no room for vengeance
[Music]
you're protecting a killer
from another killer
can you teach me how to shoot
yeah well then you put your hands behind
your back a Brig special at Rossi
my father wants you done I'll blow her
brains all over this Valley
you ain't scared of nothing
Briggs decides he's coming Paul grades
is coming he's here sound like he's the
one who's scared
my whole life I'd seen fear in the eyes
of every man I ever remember
let's do this the old way is my father
still all good man
you boy [ __ ] up the devil
[Music]
give thanks to God
the Lord is with us
what can a mere man do to me
I will come back to you
walk the earth
because I let you
I'm your God now
slaves are free
because there are many ways to die in a
swamp
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but if you don't come back
[Music]
your papa is going to be back do not
ever stop believing that he's persistent
running hiding surviving
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but they never
break me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know that love is messy
if you just give me one more chance I
will be so much better it feels like
he's really trying does that mean that I
have to start being nice to him or
something because I can't do it I don't
think not every relationship is simple
is there something you need to tell me I
want to move to New York
Daisy I'm gonna propose to Vanessa
you heard the boss
I'm looking to get a present for my
girlfriend I was hoping that one of
those blue boxes would do the trick let
me show you what we have
you're not gonna open the box no I can't
what if it is what we think it is I
don't know if I'm ready for this Merry
Christmas
[Music]
he got my ring I got his present you've
gotta go get the ring back together
all right yeah I'm fine as hell too what
are those oh my God Terry
I know something when I see something
and that wasn't nothing I'm never gonna
see him again so whatever
go again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just so close
so what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
mighty
[Music]
[Music]
we cannot let you bring your War here
outcast
that's all they see
the way of water connects all things
before your birth
and after your death
this is our home
I need you
I need you to be strong
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
another one
it's not possible the details were never
made public what are you talking about
it's just some old demons
we have a copycat on our hands people
remember the artist for the way he
murdered and preserved Six Women First
he poisoned him then the range and
decorate the corpses and lifelike poses
and call them his masterpieces how did
you guys end up catching him
damn fine detective work done by a damn
fine detectives wanted from sitting
right beside you
I'm not going in with you what do you
mean the artist is only going to play
balls we could somehow win his trust
that would be impossible with me in the
room considering my history
he actually took seven lives my partner
of 15 years two weeks from now I'm gonna
cry no world would be a better place for
it
my visit today regarding the copycat No
Doubt
if you saw some photos of the victims
maybe you would notice something that
could help us
let's cut to the chase I want my death
sentence commuted whatever help I
provide is for you and only for you
do you know if the corner clipped her
wings why would that matter for her
journey to the afterlife Fallen Angel
cast into hell to create a sculpture is
to solve a mystery by the time I finish
he'll have his exact address and
sculpting you
you realize how crazy you are
unreservedly insane he struck again
playing games with us I Heard a Voice
why am I listening to this because it's
you you know who's going to be next it's
my entire life
that is truly the stuff of nightmares
foreign
called June Mom this is FaceTime oh gosh
I need you to write a couple of things
down the car keys I just said write it
down you're not writing it down
Kevin and I are headed to LAX and we
need you to pick us up on Monday keep
your location on the entire time I'm
away no fun got it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys
my mom never came home from her trip I
don't know where she is I'm calling
about a guest you had
um does anyone speak English
Park please I need your help the FBI
doesn't have jurisdiction to investigate
in Columbia so is there anything I can
do the best thing you can do to help us
is just wait by your phone
I'm not giving up on my mom
and you can go to this hotel and ask for
their security footage
says she sees two American tourists
what did he buy just this do you think
he did something to her you're going
through Kevin's email you need to let
the police handle this I tried but we're
running out of time who are these people
this woman calls him Darren
you weren't gonna tell me my mom was
dating a felon you need to trust me on
this shocking new footage has leaked
online
I have some questions regarding
something we're looking into has your
mom ever gone by any other names
what the strangest case I've ever seen
there may be more than meets the eyes
there's
actually a lot I want to
talk oh my God
games about to start oh this time oh
what a beautiful I like Gronkowski I
know Chris we've all read your glunk
erotica it's not erotica it's fan
fiction very sexy fan fiction aren't you
tired of the same old boring lives let's
go to the Super Bowl the Super Bowl is
no place for four old women this could
be Tom's last one he's almost 40. that's
like 80 in people years yeah we're 80 in
people years I just really need this
trip
[Music]
I can't believe we're actually here
taking this one he's cute so you don't
have any tickets how much for four ten
thousand ten thousand well I have a 20
in my strap-on that's a fanny pack if
you weren't like this it's a strap-on
wow
it is so great to meet your beauty has
no expiration dates Chris I didn't flirt
he did there's so much here to do we
could even win these tickets this is a
spicy wings contest I could use a little
spice I know her you blackout who you
want me to call an ambulance oh if you
did this to give us something to
remember why honey it worked do you
think you could get us in follow me
these are my dancers prove it what dance
moves you ladies know a Twist a jerk
let's do it
[Music]
thank you
isn't that what friendship is that we
Face the unknown together let's go
Golden Girls come with me
[Music]
let's go oh my God
ready
these are good very good oh careful
they're high dosage high dosage
excuse me I'm looking for someone are
you okay
I'm Guy Fieri
quite on set let's make some Christmas
magic mark action hi there welcome to
Chloe's cakes what can I get you fellas
I'm looking for the owner Miss Chloe
Donner that is me cut
hi I'm Christopher the network wants me
to find out if Christmas movies are
worthwhile I'm gonna be on set for all
the production that's not necessary if I
had some ideas about the script do I
talk to you about those or
[Music]
here's your antagonist what are you
talking about this whole thing is a
Christmas movie we
need to play meets small town girl they
have conflict Christmas magic is like
snow in L.A there's no such thing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
people fall in love at Christmas time
that's the feeling that I always wanted
to create with my movies
[Music]
can I give you a lift what have you done
I'm embracing the Christmas movie
we have a problem I turned around it's
gone okay well she can't get off the
line wait you think she got off a lot no
no no no no sorry
making movies is exciting we're shutting
down the whole Christmas movie division
what just plan all along just pretend
you care and then pull the rug out from
under us I do care I want to be the guy
who helps create this warm comforting
safe place that the world gets to live
in at Christmas time
I want to believe him but I don't know
anymore logic doesn't say Christmas love
Saves Christmas can I trade you in for a
talking dog not according to my contract
I got her she's fine she's absolutely
fine she is fine
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this whole place is for people who want
to escape people who don't belong
anywhere else
[Music]
how do you feel I do feel a bit
no I suppose
the world has changed
[Music]
the cops give up
let them tell you what your channel
can't do
all these people I'm the only one who
knows the truth to understand me I'm the
only one foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm back on the road it's just one long
rehearsal for opening I heart radio's
Christmas Eve special let's be real for
a sec I was homeless and now I'm making
my debut on national TV
see you guys
you are the real deal Travers if it
doesn't happen someone somewhere will
give you the chance you deserve so what
can it be me
hey hey are you okay are you okay I just
killed a llama it's now pack up he's
alive and he's up welcome to Harmony
Springs Oklahoma
I have to report to La by the 24th
what's so important in L.A I Heart Radio
fancy how much is this gonna cost 2 600
bucks show our new guest here some
hospitality
[Music]
has anyone in this town ever heard of a
smartphone I had no use for fasting
around here
clearly
I have to get a job while you fix the
bus when you're done I'll have two grand
and be on my way so what do you got in a
town like this
a middle school you better start talking
one I'd like you to meet our new music
teacher I think you are all mistaken the
performance for the Christmas cows in
two weeks you prepped these kids and
I'll cover the bus repairs
[Music]
I have to write my very own song for
iHeartRadio and I'm having a hard time
sometimes when things aren't working you
unplug for a bit I haven't been to some
plug since I was eight
I'll tell you what though I'll let you
unplugged get a whole lot better I do
too
oh cause you make
place your hands over your heart this is
where you sing from not your head or
your lungs your heart
please come up for air for the first
time in years
and the only thing that changed is
the world needs to hear that voice of
yours you can't do that from here
[Music]
I always hope that my singing would
bring me to a home of my home
[Music]
home to me
welcome to Paris Joseph
Mr I fear this will not be a kind place
to such a boy
boy has talents but one in particular
that is exceptional very well
[Music]
I realized the more I sound the less I
was alone
you always so competitive
[Applause]
the show-off who spoiled Mozart's
concert May I play with you monsieur
well I hope this won't be embarrassing
for you
who the hell is that
you are quite a remarkable man
I'm Marie Antoinette queen of France
hereby anoint you Chevalier any other
country man of your color would not be
wearing such fine clothes one day the
whole world will know me and of course
the music would be spectacular
bold
you don't belong here you're a party
trick repet playing the violin that is
all
you know why it's the best
you were playing a dangerous game friend
you forget your place but break his
hands
this world is painful for us my son but
there is always
foreign
fight I'm putting on a concert let us
find the revolution
you cannot afford to make any more
enemies
this is changing you could be more
influential than you know leverage it
you take to the stage you will be erased
Filipino new front you cannot topple
what has been ordained by God
thank you
it's about you people
everybody
you need to come back now I need that
money
[Music]
like a plane to catch you're gonna come
with me and help look after the baby now
if I turn I won't press charges how is
she there she's fine how do you know if
you won't check because you give me a
little thumbs up
with late question for question but you
have to tell the truth you can't be
honest to fight with you what's the
baby's name Robin my name's Joy
I know false advertising not the bringer
of Joy apparently you're a mentalist I'm
practical and solution orientated you
just have to trust me
nothing with me honest to goodness I've
left my face at the bottom made me wash
back I might just stop the truth here
for a minute
she is the same God why are you going to
draw me to visit someone to give them
something
[Music]
all that good stuff to pass on sure have
you
come with me Molly what about my dog
we'll figure that out
you're a piece of work aren't you your
thoughts and a child keeps stolen
charity money that he wants to give back
[ __ ] off
doesn't want me Molly she won't even
take a buses from me
she thought she doesn't want you
he will keep using you until you're
spent at least my dad wants to keep me
excited anything yet what do you want me
to do Molly stop promising things
[Music]
we are gonna have the most peaceful
Christmas this year
is this we need to call an emergency
Sisters Meeting what is the Christmas
family done now it's Dad it's appeared
[Music]
dad has made several payments from a
hotel in Nevis in the Caribbean five
book tickets for the three of us we're
going to the Caribbean this afternoon
what you might want to start packing
flight leaves at four
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
can't a man disappear without being
hunted down by his nosy daughters AI I'm
here to rescue you Daddy I want you to
go back to your families aren't you just
a little bit happy to see our staff I am
staying here I think Dad is having a
massive emotional reaction well well
Jake aren't you full of surprised
another wonderful day the three of us
have to do everything we possibly can
and we have to convince him to come back
to England with us you three look like
you're up to no good
what are these call a killer bee now be
careful they're dangerous and addictive
we're gonna need some more Killer Bees
Joanna
morning I hate you
family needs to stick together
agreed agreed
[Music]
I feel a lot of change coming on James
dad wants to have fun he should have fun
who are you and what have you done with
Joanna
[Music]
very moment I am on a Caribbean island
with three of my magnificent four
daughters and I couldn't be happier
when I go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Darby Harper are you sitting down
for this I see dead people I help them
pass on to the next round
you'd think that'd be my life's biggest
burden but it is a distance second to
where I'm forced to spend my days
high school that's Capri Donahue head
cheerleader it's a cheer just for
shallow hot girls I'm so glad you asked
and the answer is that's offensive
Jeffrey knows I'm the one person she
can't get to like her Darby I thought
you went here
Capri give me my clothes why would I
take her clothes so planning on
attending the funeral she can be a
little
after sometimes extra psychotic
I'm recording live from Frederick
Douglass High School where yesterday
students witnessed the shocking death of
head cheerleader Caffrey Donahue wake up
wake up [ __ ] oh God damn it can't see
me what are you doing here my sweet 17
is coming up in a month all I want is
this party help me then I'll move on in
what world do you think I can throw your
dream party
in a world where I make you popular
enough to do it
who is that I want her but any press is
good press
[Music]
sing a dead person
he is a very traumatic experience you
look like you've just seen a ghost
this is Criminal bullying
I think it's criminally good haunting
[Music]
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
our town finding the bells how can those
be Santa's Bells when there's no such
thing as Santa of course there's really
a Santa right Mr Martin there will
always be non-believers but don't let
them rob you of your Christmas spirit
somebody stole the Bells
[Music]
are you going to cancel the Ring of the
Bell celebration absolutely not the
great town the Pleasant Bay represents
the joy and spirit of Christmas sure
found this in the garage Georgia bottoms
wait a minute
my dad didn't do this Violet you're the
smartest person I know you have to help
us
means motive opportunity this is what my
dad does at work it's how he decides
impossible suspects we have to find
another person who has all three of
these things you don't seriously think
you can solve this case do you why not
for starters you still sleep with a
stuffed animal
these are our suspects
maybe I should make this girl the new
shower are we gonna need detective stuff
I think I found some proof I think we're
done with this but there's anything I
can do to help Mr bottoms shouldn't we
at least try this is getting good
no one is going to rest until the bells
are back where they belong
[Music]
that I have a Christmas wish what is it
I want Mr bonus to be home with Kenny
for Christmas we have to find out where
it goes I don't think that's a great
idea
man up Kenny that's sexist
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but not caring
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
I have a delivery Merry Christmas thank
you Amy are you Santa it's from my
hometown snowy Oak
what
[Music]
James Hunt why did you cancel the
Christmas party come on it's the most
magical Christmas celebration we could
get a tree or some Carol Singers no
money Amy
Lots changed why didn't anyone tell me
and risk you abandoning your career to
come here
your mother would never forgive me or
ask that rich but we're income poor
things might change but this will always
be home
I know I hurt you when I left the ranch
has lost a little of her magic
Christmas is a week away so that gives
us enough time for the choir to rehearse
and for us to light up the house and get
a tree yes
yes I haven't seen June bug this happy
in a long time what happened between you
and Jennifer's mom just couldn't make it
work
how do you do that you make everything
an enchanted experience you always did
have that effect on you
I can't hit a sleigh bells ring
see you around Charlie
what do you think
it's like Christmas
family in the house again
I used to be so happy here she still
loves you James don't tell me you
haven't told her how you feel it's
complicated don't let the one get away
[Music]
the only you can decide what to do
you are literally in the DNA of this
place
magic happens at Christmas and here you
are
scenario
my heart
[Music]
[Music]